monsieur lang merci d'être avec nous
alors effondrement des ventes au mois de
mars au mois d'avril le secteur de
l'automobile a manifestement besoin dead
l'état en donnera à condition que le
secteur accepte de relocaliser est ce
que bruno le maire a raison de
conditionner son aide
alors c'est extrêmement intéressant que
bruno le maire met cela en avant c'est
effectivement une bonne idée que de
recompte de que de conditionner son aide
à la relocalisation des activités parce
qu'elle est cette relocalisation est
nécessaire et pas seulement pour des
raisons économiques avant tout pour des
raisons écologiques parce que la crise
actuelle est aussi et avant tout une
crise de résident origines écologique
donc c'est une idée extrêmement
intéressante mais j'aimerais rappeler
quand même que monsieur le maire a déjà
annoncé beaucoup de choses diverses et
variées en particulier le non versement
de l'aide de l'état pour les entreprises
qui seraient localisés dans les soi
disant paradis fiscaux est finalement
rien n'a été fait et l'assemblée n'a
même pas retenu cette proposition
donc il faut faire très attention aux
effets d'annoncé et puis il faut faire
attention aussi à ce qu'il entend par
compétitivité si c'est pour eux localisé
chez nous et pour baisser les coûts dans
le secteur de l'automobile
je ne suis pas convaincu que ce soit
forcément une bonne idée
est-ce que selon vous l'industrie
automobile française a vraiment trop
délocaliser comme le dit bruno le maire
oui enfin la plupart des industries ont
fortement délocaliser y compris en
allemagne d'ailleurs les allemands
produisent des voitures haut de gamme
donc qu'ils sont compétitifs non pas en
raison de leur prix mais en raison de
leur qualité mais eux aussi ils ont
délocalisé bon dont six appels leur
hinterland
c'est à dire les pays autour de
l'allemagne comme la pologne qui sont
qui sont beaucoup moins chers donc
effectivement monsieur le maire a raison
de dire ça maintenant méfions nous des
effets d'annoncé voyons concrètement
déjà premièrement s'il ya eu six tout
cela débouche une proposition de loi et
deuxièmement comment est-ce qu'il veut
mettre tout cela en oeuvre
il ne suffit pas de proposer des aides
de l'état temporaire localiser et c'est
une fois de plus si c'est pour essayer
de se positionner en termes de conte sur
la compétitivité c'est vraiment pas la
peine les industriels automobile
française on a un certain nombre de
filiales françaises comme valeo comme
michelin qui sont extrêmement
intéressants
maintenant si on veut les rues
relocaliser c'est une très bonne chose
maintenant il faut il faut voir quels
seraient les contreparties et en
particulier en termes de qualité de
l'emploi en termes de salaires et en
termes de respect de l'environnement
alors question en général mais comment
l'industrie automobile va sortir de
cette crise du commun 19 sa part
extrêmement difficile mais elle va s'en
sortir
à mon avis il faudrait que maintenant
qu'elle se met très sérieusement aux
voitures qui sont moins polluantes
ça va correspondre à une demande
croissante dans le secteur automobile
il faudrait qu'elle se met sérieusement
à monter en gamme l'industrie française
pour essayer un peu de rattraper les
allemands là dessus voilà alors pour
finir on le sait le coronavirus a
paralysé à toute l'économie avec mon
avis mondiale et l'économie nationale
c'est une question vaste mais comment
voyez-vous la pré coronavirus
économiquement je veux dire et pas pour
les entreprises et pour les français
pour les particuliers est ce qu'ils vont
ressentir cette thèse est un hamiti moi
ma crainte c'est que les gouvernements
la sortir de la crise se disent il ya
trop de dettes publiques il va falloir
les réduire et qu'ils refassent les
erreurs qui ont été faites en do mineur
qui ont fait que on est passé très près
de la déflation dans la zone euro donc
si on refait le même type d'erreur il
faut s'attendre à une situation
extrêmement compliquée on va voir dans
les semaines à venir les situations dans
cette entreprise il ya un quart des
entreprises qui risquent de faire
faillite et donc on va se retrouver avec
des ménages qui vont se retrouver au
chômage
donc on va se retrouver dans une
situation extrêmement compliquée si
l'état ne met pas au beau et si l'état
n'intervient pas massivement et
durablement dans l'économie c'est
peut-être le moment de mettre les moyens
là où sont les besoins c'est à dire dans
l'hôpital dans la transition écologique
donc
donc si l'état n'intervient pas et si au
contraire l'état lève le pied pour
soi-disant rembourser la dette
il va aggraver la situation et donc les
mois à venir seront préoccupant à la
fois pour les ménages les français les
entreprises donc pour tout le monde
alors on ne sait pas en parler par
exemple du secteur automobile qui lui
aussi a bénéficié des prêts garantis par
l'état dpe le gouvernement aussi il a
mis en place le chômage partiel et l'a
investi gens me dire dans le secteur
économique français qui a été frappé de
plein fouet par le coronavirus mais à ce
que l'exécutif en a fait assez et est ce
qu'il a fait à ses taux alors à mon avis
c'est une bonne chose qu'on on a dû
arrêter notre économie pour faire face à
ce virus
donc c'est une bonne chose qu'on ait mis
en place le type de mesures qui ont été
mis en place après les prêts garantis
par l'état
le problème c'est que c'est à la bonne
volonté des banques donc vous avez un
certain d'entreprise qui n'en n'ont
aucunement bénéficier qui n'en n'ont pas
vu la couleur
donc ces entreprises aujourd'hui sont
dans une difficulté majeure de la même
manière le chômage partiel c'était une
très bonne chose mais on nous a d'ores
et déjà annoncé la fin de ce chômage
partiel à la fin du mois de juin alors
que
il est clair que les ménages ne sont qui
ont des enfants ne sont pas certains de
pouvoir mettre leurs enfants à l'école
sans courir de risques majeurs et sans
faire courir de risques à leurs enfants
donc maintenant il va falloir voir dans
les mois à venir quelles seront les
règles qu'ils seront les réactions
d'économie française on nous annonce
déjà qu'un quart des pme risquent de
faire faillite
donc on risque de se retrouver dans une
situation extrêmement difficile donc
l'état a fait en partie ce qu'il fallait
mais plutôt que des prêts garantis par
l'état il fallait contraindront si les
banques à raccorder ces prêts parce
qu'elles ont été extrêmement frileuses
en particulier à l'attention des pme et
des pmi qui sont quand même le coeur
économique et social de notre nation
dany langues
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
maître de conférences à l'université
paris xiii merci à vous